hey guys today I want to share with you
10 things that I do every day to have a
Purpose Driven fulfilled and peaceful
life a Victorious Life and let me kick
it off by giving you this quote that I
believe every man should know and live
by CS Lewis said it is not your business
to succeed but to do right when you have
done so the rest lies with God this is
the way I live my life I do the right
thing no matter what other people say or
even when no one is looking I do the
right thing and then I can be happy
content with whatever happens because I
know I've done the right thing I've done
my best and the rest is up to God
whatever happens will happen I can't
change that but I have peace in my soul
and I can sleep good at night now let's
start with the first thing that you need
to do every day to live live a
Victorious
[Music]
Life make your bed and clean your room
and let me say it as it is have enough
respect for yourself to not live like a
pig if your room in house for that
matter are cluttered and things are just
lying around everywhere then it says a
lot about the way you choose to live
your life and it shows in your
relationships your work and in
everything you do living this Way shows
you are
lazy
disorganized and that you do not take
responsibility for your own
mess and you cannot even do the first
task of the day so how are you going to
do the rest
successfully if you cannot even trust
yourself with the little
things what's going to happen with the
big things this should be your first
task of the day and when you have done
it the rest will all fall into place
because you will have the the right
mindset workout workout is not so much
for me about improving my body and
looking good for my wife of course that
helps but that's not the main reason
it's actually about improving my whole
life my health self-discipline and
mental health working out increases your
adrenaline and energy that goes to the
brain and improves memory and over a
period of time working out consistently
helps with the creation of new brain
cells in the
hippocampus I bet a lot of you didn't
know that huh and in aart from that it
also man it prevents so many health
risks and prevention is always better
than just waiting for it and then
getting sick or getting a health problem
that you will struggle with for the rest
of your life it reduces the risk of high
cholesterol high blood pressure
inflammation diabetes cancer and so much
more guys you need to be healthy in mind
body and spirit so you got to take care
of your body if you don't what do you
think is going to happen you only have
one body you're not going to get another
one and then for a lot of men regret
comes too late when you're stuck with
health problems we're not meant to just
sit in front of the computer the whole
day and just
work you're meant to be active so go out
there work out enjoy life and be at 100%
all all the
time three good grooming I've said this
before on this channel it is wrong to be
vain right and you get your
self-confidence and everything else from
the way you look that is wrong because
that comes from God but you need to have
enough respect for yourself made in the
image of God that you take care of your
body the only body that God gave you
which if you are reborn Christian is a
temple of God so be thankful to God and
take care
of yourself look tidy neat professional
and approachable to all people if you
don't groom yourself you will look lazy
unprofessional and unapproachable this
is what I do in a nutshell to get ready
for the day a quick shower I will add
all the grooming products I believe in
and use personally for you in the video
description down below geology for my
hair care and skincare is the most
important it works because it's
personalized skincare they sent to me
each month that works for my unique skin
which helps my dry skin dark circles
under my eyes blackheads prevent pimples
and give me clear skin next I do a quick
beer trim if needed then I shave the
hair on my cheeks neck and
sides next is sea salt spray I use it to
dry my hair into the style I want and
finish it with American Crew Pomade and
maybe a touch of hairspray if necessary
that's it grooming done always look
professional neat and approachable now
again I'll add all the details for in
the video description down below and
also a discount code for
Geology read the Bible and pray with
coffee this is the most important time
of the day for me this is where I get my
energy from this is where I get my
purpose my my peace my joy my everything
I need this is where I get it from to be
able to to stand strong against all the
storms that this life can bring it
doesn't matter because I'm rooted in
Christ and he gives me what I need if I
start my day with God then nothing of
this temporary world can get me down
because I live by a real faith and not
by side which helps me to see what
normal people can't enabling me to act
in God confidence and not
self-confidence eat a healthy but tasty
food
this is so important one of the most
important things because a lot of people
think that when they start to eat a
healthy that it's not going to be tasty
it's so wrong you just need to find the
the healthy food that's tasty for you
this is extremely important for me to
live a consistently healthy life that
will help me to always be at 100% to
always be healthy so for breakfast I
love to eat oats with mixed nuts berries
and whey protein for lunch and dinner I
choose any healthy meat and preferably
green vegetables I also love eggs
whether it's scrambled poached or o
omelets it is so important to live a
healthy balanced life and a lot of
people complain because they're so tired
and sometimes they feel depressed and a
lot of it has got to do with the food
that you eat so you just improve that
and it improves the rest but it is
important to eat the thing things you
love so try different healthy food and
then just stick to the healthy food that
you actually love to
eat schedule your priorities if you have
a lot of things to do it is important to
focus on the things that's the most
important and do
that for me running two Ministries DM
men's Lifestyle the Christian
lifestyle now also starting Rock
entertainment there are all certain
things that I will need to sacrifice
because I don't have enough time to do
everything I really want to do so I need
to look at the things that are the most
important for that day and then do it so
DM Christian lifestyle and also men's
lifestyle with all its video editing
thumbnails social media marketing emails
Team Management all the meetings
everything takes a lot of time then
we're also starting up Ro entertainment
which of course I can't talk about yet
but it takes a lot of time so so I will
literally sit down and ask myself this
important question what are the most
important things that I need to take
care of
today and I write them down some of the
things I can remember but if I'm a
little bit afraid that I might not
remember certain things I write it down
if you want to reach your big goals you
need to reach all the small goals that
will take you to the Big Goal you need
structure in your daily routine to
achieve those daily goals that will help
you to get closer to the big goals if
you only dream about it and do nothing
not having a plan you are planning to
fail and those dreams will just stay
dreams everyone just gets 24 hours in a
day and those who achieve their goals
with hard work are just those who use 24
hours better than other
people do what needs to be done even if
you don't feel like it man this is
something my mother burned into my
brain even today I can just hear her
voice right
now we all have to do certain things
that we don't like at certain times to
get closer to the things we really want
most out of life and this is true even
with the little things in life for
example you might not like taking 30
minutes to prepare a tasty meal but once
you eat it it is all worth
it and then another example is you might
not like working out right but what you
really want is a good fit body to be
healthy and if you don't have one you
have to do workouts you have to eat
healthy which you might not like in the
beginning but as you start to see the
results with consistency 1 month 2
months 3 months and you see the changes
then you start liking it and then you
endure it you go to the gym you do what
needs to to be done to reach your goal
the things that you really care about
that are worth it to
pursue often requires hard work and
doing things that you don't like that's
temporary to get you to the thing you
really want that you want most in life
so stop complaining pull up your socks
and do what must be done even if you
don't like it no
excuses make coffee for
someone I'm actually serious if you live
a life where you're at work for example
and you just always make coffee for
yourself that's a selfish life which is
an unhappy life the little things matter
coffee is just an example you see living
life in such a way where you care about
other people and do small things for
them like making a quick coffee which
takes so little time might be the
greatest thing they experience that day
then suddenly the next day you go and
they ask if you want coffee and then you
start to realize oh wait a minute my
actions create reactions from other
people and that improves your social
life he start to enjoy your
relationships with other people people
start to care about you because they
feel that you care about them and
suddenly you have an amazing social life
one of the worst things in this world is
to be
alone even when there are people around
you find the moment to smell the flowers
a lot of guys out there Focus so much on
The Daily
Grind that they kind of lose themsel in
their work they burn themselves out and
they forget to enjoy
life for some reason they start to
falsely believe that they will only
start to enjoy life once they reach
their goals they want to chase their
dreams so hard because they think that
that's the only thing that's going to
make them happy that's wrong they forget
that the journey is actually more
important than the dream because once
they reach it the top of the mountain
they realize that it was all about the
journey because now they need another
dream again they lost their purpose so
stop and smell the flowers on your
journey Journey make time to enjoy life
and don't wait until you reach your
goals or retire because you don't even
know if you're going to live that long
you can die tomorrow look for the flower
every day look for that special moment
every day and when you find it stop the
time and take it all
in don't just live to exist but exist to
live life and enjoy life appreciate
everything that God has given you
remember John 10:10 says the thief comes
only to steal and kill and destroy I
came that they may have life and have it
abundantly the last one number 10 thank
God for every day I mean it appreciate
every day that you have been given
because life is is a gift your life just
a fact that you can listen to this video
that you can breathe that you can watch
that you can hear it is a gift in the
morning when I pray to God I make it a
habit to first thank him for another day
to appreciate it you know most people
can have a better life instantly by just
changing your outlook on life you choose
how you want to look at life and how you
react to everything you experience in
life a lot of people are negative
pessimistic unnecessarily living that
way they're allowing the Devil to come
in and steal their Joy don't let him
steal your joy but look to Christ look
to truth look at the light live in the
light not in the darkness if you do that
you will start to understand that you
cannot find peace Joy everything you
need that fulfillment
you cannot find it from temporary things
you find it only from God himself that
guards your heart and your mind with
peace that you cannot explain that
surpasses all understanding because you
live in that relationship with him you
can choose to live this way a good
example is Psalm 118: 24 this is the day
that the Lord has made let us rejoice
and be glad in it I choose to live my
life in the truth according to God's
word and let me tell you life is good
even in trials and
tribulations it surpasses even my
understanding how I can have peace in
even the most difficult times in my life
now go out there and live life in God
confidence not in self-confidence and if
you don't know what that means what is
God confidence then please watch this
video here and I'll see you there and
always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours cheers guys